remember that out video oh hey don't ya
oh look who this hey what's up it's me
the Hitler guy I guess hey doable ish
like two days off in the video aired are
not aired the gun on the internet my car
was totaled I had the bricks thrown
through it and the words racist were my
experiment out of my car yeah I did
girlfriend you try to force her to do
that did ya I did how do you feel about
that you know I was totally against it
I'm not as mean as this guy hey doable
ish but it's ok because i am a cruel
cruel person hi hi hi oh hi oh since you
had a grand buffet hi grandma say
everyone go see grandma Faye they're
from Pittsburgh there ought to tell me a
little story oh oh my story is i guess
that i saw Justine's video on myspace
featured videos though and i found her
blog and then itís all my friends to it
shooting your last be like the girl $200
maxvill and i was like don't mean to
seem so excited she's here being part of
our friends video no I'm so excited this
is me jumping accepted fake jumping cuz
I'm just moving the camera okay my
friends but stay by my side